a
[Música]
estas están siendo las elecciones
presidenciales más atípicas de las
últimas cuatro décadas de esta
revolución islámica donde las elecciones
son vistas como un referendo un primero
por la pandemia que impide esos grandes
encuentros que suelen haber en estos
tiempos de los candidatos con sus
seguidores y aún así si no hubiera
pandemia la situación seguiría
posiblemente un poco parecida por el
descontento de la población hacia el
gobierno y hacia el régimen que lleva a
que muchos no quieran votar uno de sus
problemas es el descontento por la
situación económica a la cual apuntan al
gobierno saliente de hassan roja ni pero
también a la decisión del consejo de
guardianes de eliminar a la mayoría de
candidatos moderados y reformistas son
siete candidatos cinco de ellos
conservadores radicales y muchos piensan
que el presidente ya está elegido o por
lo menos es el que mayor campaña tiene y
es el clérigo ibrahim raeissi
[Música]
en oriente medio' y particularmente en
egipto pocos creen que vaya a cambiar
nada después de estas elecciones en irán
en las últimas semanas las columnas de
opinión hablaban de políticas nefastas
que se han llevado a cabo durante los
últimos 40 años tanto a nivel doméstico
como a nivel internacional lo que habría
provocado que irán haya convertido a
cualquier país en oriente medio' en un
enemigo creen que eso no va a cambiar lo
que sí creen que ha cambiado es el
discurso religioso los ciudadanos
iraníes están mucho más preocupados
ahora por los problemas sociales y por
los problemas económicos que por la
religión creen los egipcios los
columnistas egipcios que eso tampoco va
a cambiar y que es el motivo por el que
muchos ciudadanos no están interesados
en estas elecciones creen que debería
ocurrir un milagro para que el nuevo
presidente dejara de ser una marioneta
del líder supremo
[Música]
irán no les hagan a israel desde ningún
punto de vista no desde el político
tampoco desde el periodístico y nivel
cultural aquí se reciben noticias de lo
que sucede en el país vecino que desde
que se convirtió en la república
islámica también se convirtió en el
archienemigo de israel los medios
israelíes algunos de ellos son
traducidos al persa y también hay una
radio persa de manera que hay un fluir
ir y venir de información es lo que
sorprende es que en esta convocatoria
electoral iraní casi no se ha mencionado
nada en los medios de comunicación
masivos israelíes se ha consignado la
fecha los candidatos y poco más lo que
explicaría esta ignorancia o pasar por
alto la elección presidencial iraní es
que el consenso israelí es que en irán a
quien decide es el ayatolá también a los
candidatos que van a presentarse a
presidente y por muy progresista que sea
el presidente no va a tener gran
capacidad de maniobra bajo el liderazgo
del ayatolá
[Música]